hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing paul
morphy's 1858 simultaneous exhibition in
paris and
this is the fourth game we're showing uh
from the exhibition he already won
three of them very nicely and here his
opponent is a gentleman we know nothing
about bernard c
birwirth and we know nothing about him
and
we do not have a photo of him so as
usual now we are honoring him
by wearing a hoodie and um like i said
it's uh
so far i think morphy's biggest
challenge that we're showing in the
simultaneous exhibition but
uh let's see if he was able to overcome
such a challenge
so without further ado let's check it
out the morphe with the white pieces
opens with e4 we have e6
going for the french defense d4 and now
c6 here
uh olavental also mentions that um
for some reason uh when uh opponents
were playing against morphy and morphe
was
blindfolded or rather playing without
any actual sight of the board because he
was playing in one room and all of the
other players
eight of them were playing in the in the
different room
and they were uh either shouting moves
or they were you know sending someone to
uh send morphe the the move so uh
someone
even asked this in the comments section
of the previous video no morphe did not
see any of the boards of the players he
was playing against
so here a c6 sort of a measure of uh
trying to confuse morphy but morphy not
really impressed by this he just
continues developing with bishop to d3
and now d5 striking in the center but
now morphy happily captures because now
his light square bishop comes alive
and black might have some uh developing
issues uh
regarding his development so here uh c
captures on d5 is what you should play
uh but here uh our good friend
beeruv uh decides to go for e captures
on d5
and it's already as of move forward that
this position has never been reached
again
uh so let's see how morphy continues we
have knight to f3 preparing to castle
and bishop to g4 now makes sense you
want to pin the knight we have castles
by morphy
and bishop to d6 now black also going
for some very rapid development we have
h3
and now bishop to h5 and not capturing
of course with bishop to e3
uh morphy always enjoyed developing his
bishops to d3 and e3 this is like a
signature morphe developing move uh
knight to d7
uh and now rook the e1 threatening some
nasty discoveries
so knight the e7 blocking that and now
knight b to d2
all of the pieces are now developed you
now need to bring the queen into the
game
connect rooks and then figure out a game
plan and here
and a nice idea for black might be
something like knight to f8 followed by
knights the e6 could be
a wonderful square for the knight but
here uh uh beeruvert
decides to go for bishop captures on f3
instead
and okay knight captures the f3 by
morphy and h6 he takes away the g5
square for morphe's pieces
and uh okay it does make sense to an
extent so here queen d2
morphe develops the queen connects the
rooks and now queen to c7 now black
might castle kingside he might castle
queenside
so a lot of ideas here morphe strikes in
the center we have c4
very principled as the opponent's king
is still in the center of the board
and d captures on c4 we have bishop
captures on c4
and now black needs to decide what to do
you can't very well remain in the center
of the board that's going to be too
dangerous
uh do you go king side you go queen side
or what do you play here
uh going for castles right away doesn't
really work because morphy just plays
bishop captures on h6 and that's a game
so that's out of the question the
problem is if you go for this
queen captures there is not much you can
do to defend the position
uh for example if bishop f4 you can
attack the queen just knight g5
again threatening checkmate you don't
care if black captures the knight
if bishop captures you're going to
capture with check and now
again there is no uh good move here
whatever you play that's just it if you
play
uh well you could move the king but it's
uh you know without
any uh any real worth rook to e4 and
this is now going to result in checkmate
and of course you could also block
but it's not actually blocking just
queen captures and the f pawn is pinned
so there's also that
so castling from this position not the
greatest
of ideas and black of course knows this
he could castle queen side but then the
f7 pawn is hanging
so also not maybe the greatest of ideas
so he plays
f5 uh gets rid of the target on f7 and
now just prepares the castle queen side
but now
morphy's position is uh well uh
something very well uh can be can be
played here so feel free to pause the
video
and try to find this mysterious move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a
such a wonderful idea it's not an easy
one to spot and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's knight
to e5
and it seems like you're just uh
offering uh you know some material to
your opponent but there is no good way
to capture this problem is
if you go for knight captures on e5 and
d captures what
do you play here with black you can't
very well move the bishop there are no
squares for the bishop
you would have to capture here and then
just bishop c5
attacks the bishop uh the if you move
the bishop then the knight
will be under attack from the rook and
the bishop there really is no good move
here
if rook d8 you go after the queen
there's always queen e to
just introduce another attacker here and
if knight the g6 now kind of defending
and guarding
the df4 square twice queen h5 and you
just
grab this knight so this obviously will
not work the bishop pair is just uh
uh well they are quite the team
as you can imagine so here after this
idea uh this will not work so after
knight to e5
capturing with the knight doesn't work
capturing with the bishop however might
work
but it doesn't a d captures an e5 and
again there is no good way to capture
the pawn
if you go for queen captures on e5 then
just well pretty much whatever you can
just go bishop f4 and that's it
uh the queen has to move somewhere and
there's no good square if queen here
then bishop here you're gonna lose the
knight next
and that's it and instead of this if you
don't go for
uh the the uh this capture if you go for
a different capture for example knight
captures on e5
not much better bishop f4 with a double
attack on the knight
and if knight the g6 defending this and
attacking the bishop
uh not a problem just captures captures
and now whatever uh queen to d4
that you're going to lose this knight
that's that's game
uh so yeah after this knight the e5 the
knight can't very well be captured so
here we have
castles queen side instead and now
offering morphy to go for knight f7
which is of course a great move it
attacks both of the rooks and it's an
easy material game
but morphy never goes for material like
almost never and instead he goes for
bishop to e6 he keeps the pressure on
and says i can always play this unless
you want to capture my knight and here
uh well
uh beeruv decided to capture the knight
as there is nothing uh there's nothing
better here so bishop captures was
played
d captures and now king the b8 this pawn
is off limits yet again because if you
go for queen captures on e5
bishop f4 and again there is no move for
black
the bishop is nicely defended you have
to move the queen somewhere
all of these squares are taken you have
to play something then just queen d6 and
queen to c7 will be checkmate so
out of the question so after d captures
on e5 we have king to b8 now unpinning
and now maybe the knight can capture
and now morphy just plays queen to c3
again offering the e5 pawn
but again the e5 pawn cannot be captured
because if knight captures just bishop
f4
now there's a triple attack on this
knight here and if you don't capture
with the knight but ryder with the queen
of course not much better bishop
captures an a7 with check
picks up the queen now very very good
stuff
so here after queen to c3 knight the b6
now blocking this bishop's attack to the
a7 pawn
and now morphy just goes for queen to a3
and morphy is always very very skillful
with the queen
he just finds all of the deadliest
squares now the knight is paralyzed
because queen captures an a7 would
happen
and what do you play here morphy also
has a past e
pawn that still cannot be captured you
can never capture this because there are
too many too many discoveries just
lurking so here at knight b
the c8 now the knight guards the a7
square of course
you cannot eliminate it because then the
other knight takes its place
so instead after knight b to c we have
rook 8 c1
just bringing the rook to the nice semi
open c file and now
black says all right you don't have
anything here on the queen side i'm just
going to start attacking you on the king
side and
go g5 so now morphe doesn't want to meet
f4 and
be forced to move his bishop from this
diagonal so he plays f4 himself
g captures an f4 bishop captures and now
rook to d4 putting pressure on morphy's
bishop
probably going for if morphe goes bishop
e3 i'm gonna go rook to e4
and then i'm going to go finally after
this e5 pawn
if i can eliminate this should be good
for me but instead we have queen to e3
by morphy
now attacking the rook and rook to e for
now chasing the queen
queen to f3 and now queen to b6
with check now we have king to h2 the
king will be very safe there
and now um uh captures will rook
captures rook captures and the queen to
be
for now so what do you do here uh
there's pressure on the bishop the
the the rook on e1 is under attack the
b2 pawn is hanging so how do you defend
all of this
uh rook to e2 this is what morphy plays
everything is now nicely defended we
have knight to g6 now with a double
attack on the bishop here on f4 and
morphy just retreats
bishop to d2 attacking the queen so
while you could capture on b2 then
morphy has a discovery bishop captures
an h6 wins the h6
pawn with an attack on the queen while
it's playable
it doesn't really do all that much so
here queen to b5 is played
uh but now morphy finally says all right
you've played well you've defended well
i
i wasn't able to completely crush you so
i have to resort
you know to this to the lowest possible
way of winning and that's by you know uh
grabbing material and
winning the game uh you know uh with
that kind of an advantage which for
morphe
i'm sure it wasn't easy so morphy played
bishop captures on c8
now saying that okay if king captures
then i can eliminate this f5 pawn with
check i'm not gonna win the knight
because the rook on e2 is hanging but
after you move
the king i'm gonna play queen e4 and
then push the pass pawn to victory
uh so instead uh rook captures on c8 was
played
but now a morphe just goes for bishop
captures on h6
uh and this is how you know you are a
good chess player when you force morphe
to grab a pawn and then uh decide
the game via via material so he can feel
definitely very good about himself
so here rook back to h8 going after the
bishop now bishop g7
uh we have rook to h7 now bishop to f6
everything is nicely defended and now
this pass pawn is ready to march forward
we rook the
f7 now uh if e6 then we can capture the
the bishop here so that's not a problem
uh but now morphy just goes for queen to
h5
and there are no more good moves for
black black tried one thing
i'll also show another thing that black
didn't try if you go knight captures an
e5 it seems like it's possible
uh but uh it's actually not because just
queen h8 check and that's it queen eight
trade for example king here and
this will just be checkmate uh the king
has nowhere
to go the the famous mating pattern that
we've mentioned several times already
so here after queen to h5 uh morphy's
opponent
tried knight to f4 with a nice fork the
rook and the queen are under attack
uh but here it's actually just lost uh
here morphe played queen captures on f7
and it was in this position that his
opponent
who we know nothing of bernard c
beerwith resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
uh once you recapture the piece uh it's
just checkmate queen eight
check king c7 and queen to d8 will be
checkmate again
it's very interesting that morphe even
grabbed the rook because you don't have
to grab it
uh for example the game could uh could
go on
if morphe plays a queen captures here
and his opponent just plays something
like uh well
pawn here of course black is still
completely uh lost but
at least he could uh you know make
morphe suffer for
like maybe 20 more moves uh but he
didn't after queen captures on f7
he just resigned the game but you don't
have to capture it you can just play
queen to h8 to check
and it's a checkmate right away either
you first give up the rook captures and
checkmate on d8 or king to c7 and then
this will just be checkmate
so this is a very very rare case of
morphe not going for the
quickest idea for the for the instant
kill
uh and uh well also very very nice to
notice that um
there are games when even morphe was
able to miss this but okay
we can forgive him as he did play all of
the games blindfolded simultaneously
uh so that's the fourth game we were
showing from the paris simultaneous
exhibition hope you guys enjoyed that
one
and yeah as you can see most of these
games are available also with annotation
of
our good friend yohanyako bleventhal uh
as he uh really really enjoyed
uh analyzing more of his games and also
saying how morphy you know could have
played better here could have played
better there but then when he finally
faced morphe we all know how then
that ended if you don't start the morphe
saga from the beginning the first link
in the description below
so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
jack uh paul hinnermund uh uh edward
vivian
nigeriac and david kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day